after more than three decades in power
lebanon's Central Bank Governor is
stepping down Riyad salami spent his
final weeks in office as an
international fugitive wanted by
Interpol on embezzlement charges he's
also leaving a financial system and an
economy in Ruins while people have been
locked out of their deposits in Banks
anger has been directed at him
but the long-serving governor denies any
wrongdoing and says the central bank
finance governments and didn't spend the
funds many dispute that
he was the Chief Financial Officer of
the entire Lebanese political Financial
oligarchy of the Lebanese Mafia and this
is why an overwhelming majority of the
Lebanese population today is extremely
frustrated because there was no
accountability and he's going back home
it wasn't too long ago that lebanon's
top politicians argued salami should
remain in his position despite
corruption probes at home and abroad but
they've been silent since the
International arrest warrants against
him were issued by France and Germany
salami however won't be extradited these
rulers have stolen the people they stole
their money and they never they were
never held accountable definitely and we
have we have lots of evidence that a lot
of them have transferred money even when
they knew that the collapse is going to
happen and they transferred millions and
millions of dollars losses are in the
billions of dollars mostly blamed on
Decades of mismanagement and Corruption
by a political Elite who have been in
power since the end of the Civil War in
1990.
stronger than the state they've been
resisting reforms that would stop them
profiting
instead they are locked in a power
struggle unable to elect a president
without one the government remains a
caretaker Administration and it makes it
difficult to appoint a successor to
salami
for now the vice Governor will assume
responsibility but without the political
class agreeing on monetary and financial
policies to bring in much needed
International funding salami's departure
won't Mark A New Beginning for Lebanon
Beirut
foreign